[Applause]
[Music]
on that look at Aaron Gordon
shoulder-to-shoulder with boots nowhere
for J Michael de green to go and Evan
puts it right where it needs to be just
two points there in the first half and
no field goals and five attempts he's
got a chance here that is hey for sure
two points for the man to only his
second dunk of the year and for a switch
Isaac with the steal for the magic ahead
to Gordon helped dunk it in nice job
Jonathan Isaac you defensive play
[Music]
well-executed
- the time is perfect backdoor cut by
Neal Williams
[Applause]
by Gordon three-on-two Terrence Ross too
far underneath to Aaron Gordon nearness
it in order to breach of it occupy the
same territory crossover by eg slams it
down Gordon coming off a couple of big
games 23 on Monday night against
Cleveland with the magic trail the
Pistons by three
[Music]
[Applause]
six out Aaron George oh yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
nowhere to go
Aaron Gordon backing in on John yes we
could this is a special move here the
back down the quick spin and the dunk
she'd know where he is in transition the
one through the rebound
throws it long before the gap behind the
Washington defense system nice job Aaron
Gordon releasing on the shot taken away
by DJ four-on-one
brought back alone
my goodness he's a high-flyer heron
garden lucha [ __ ] going at him again
out the Gordon these slabs at all
with a nice finish your one dude boarded
easy to AG will be without the
basketball right into West's vision he
has seven individually ultra vision
comes to the ball nice feet mind the
head throw down about a G on the back
cut here terrific pass little some extra
to take with you it wasn't your usual
where you just you know thinking through
it who bunch of its feeds Gordon esteem
the rebound 14 seconds left
magic play keep-away Gordon takes the
two and the Lakers take timeout with the
magic up by four against his team before
rebounding teams in the league with
Phoenix Suns just overpowering a reason
you mentioned his defensive ability he
is a good on the ball defender flip
early with this favorable matchup quick
spin to the baselines a reason on
developing being get comfortable with
the footwork necessary to be a good
three-point shooter this summer
flying high for the dunk pretty nice
right here Eric Gordon lets it flies
that's no good rebound is banded to the
floor picked up by Augustine Gordon
through the backdoor
[Applause]
steal by Gordon he's off to the races
McClure will not even attempt recorded
ties the score at 55 the baselines
during the two-minute mark in the fourth
quarter
underneath this one is their what a play
by Aaron Gordon to the basket by Aaron
Gordon and the foul on Bullock in a
pretty good job playing Evan Fournier
off the Drive just lost sight of Aaron
work slicing down the middle Bullock
[Applause]
this Sunday afternoon at Central Florida
for the hometown Orlando Magic number
nine in white out there the guy that's
got the ball right now is weren't in
all-star Jersey how about that - my
boots of it but midway in the first
quarter take it away by Augustin a poor
pass by the rookie Aaron Gordon in the
floor but DJ with the confidence to
throw the lot of opportunities rocks
with the steal at midcourt
[Applause]
to watch the great hands by Terrence
Ross kicking across the court 11:40 a
heads up Eric Gordon coming right down
the lane 48 that it back shot clock at
Fort Gordon came open at the last second
a minute to play in the food for de
globo for Aaron Gordon a little
miscommunication where the guys in white
it can all be in set up like Griffins
that's not talking but no movement there
is G going right down the lane
[Music]
[Applause]
that gets the crowd stirred up he come
right there soaring in candidate for our
fight of the game Simmons
rebounded by Jared grey warden Duncan
boarding flight of the game brought to
you by the Orlando International Airport
had a feeling this might be a candidate
or a forget that the size and the foul
switching here David and Aragorn doing a
nice job cut right behind Noel right
there to cut him off but using that
bigger body able to ceiling Gordon
alley-oop gets a little space behind Taj
Gibson two in the post we run the
offense good things happen bad defensive
play Jonathan Isaac Gautam get that lob
and the lab at beats their hand finds it
open to Aaron Gordon she seems to be
feeling good and Rick Williams
attacking Gordon with the deflection and
the steal here comes Gordon he'll throw
it down we're just coming out of the
locker room with great intensity
[Applause]
last pick-and-roll recorded he changed
it again Aaron Gordon uncontested above
the rim
miles fumbled it away Terrence Ross
Aaron Gordon good job by AG will that
lead now back up to eight for tour of
Memphis feel like this Toronto will all
these former rafters
Aaron Gordon gets to back for the magic
Gordon went up strong stops it in and a
foul it might be Valanciunas I think it
is if it is it will be his third warden
steps in an EP Oleg off the dribble a
big part of the battle here tonight
absolutely they've done 27 of Miami's 55
Gordon miss a shot in close not just
that one out and follow Ross
[Applause]
[Music]
Burch banging and ball around
Griffin powering his way in missed a
couple we founded by Orlando it's
Augustine to us to face of it dumps its
equipment when Casey will take time out
team to nothing in points off Colonel
favor of New York boots a [ __ ] with
another assist in the first warrant
Isaac's for three Bochy [ __ ] poor Lynn
is there to pick up the loose ball
Jordan completed the play a that the
Knicks make a bigger comeback and Paul
on the road to Damascus right now
Jordan with the slam underneath that a
tremendous episode I don't wouldn't say
other than hitting the offensive doors
which just helped their offense they
should see the frustration from
Charlotte the siakam pretty spin
couldn't put it down boy DJ Augustine
talked about his big game worthier I had
three ladies Martin with a vicious to
edit finish what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content